[Música]
la invasión rusa de ucrania el programa
nuclear iraní la bomba norcoreana o el
expansionismo chino en el mar de la
china meridional el mundo amigos está
que arde y la cuestión militar vuelve a
ocupar el primer plano de la política
internacional porque además la agresión
de vladimir putin a ucrania y está
provocando un enorme terremoto
geopolítico ya nadie se fía de ese
vecino que nos saluda casi nunca que
grita más de la cuenta y que nos
resultaba particularmente amigable la
pesadilla desatada por el kremlin nos ha
recordado a todos que lo inimaginable es
perfectamente posible así que en estos
casos el precavido vale por dos nos
parece lo estamos viendo en europa donde
prácticamente todos los países están
anunciando inversiones militares récords
para los próximos años desde el más
pequeño como estonia hasta el más grande
como alemania y también sobre todo lo
podemos ver en asia-pacífico porque no
se podemos decir que últimamente las
relaciones de china con la mayor parte
de sus vecinos no pasan precisamente por
su mejor momento
china se está convirtiendo en una
superpotencia y el gobierno decide en
pin ha comenzado a ser mucho más
imperativo en las cuestiones regionales
ahora bien hasta qué punto puede
enfriarse sus vecinos de un país como
china que pueden hacer para no sucumbir
ante el gigante pues amigos eso es
exactamente lo que explica noticias cómo
está el gasto militar de asia aumentó un
2,8 por ciento en 2021 contrarrestando
la caída global del 18 por ciento y
claro ahora tras la guerra de ucrania
pues hasta japón le ha visto las orejas
al lobo y esto qué quiere decir pues
amigos que tal y como está ocurriendo en
europa también aquí la mayoría de países
están preparando los cheques para
incrementar su gasto militar y ojo
porque en este punto tenemos que tener
algo muy en cuenta si china se ha
convertido en la gran potencia regional
de asia-pacífico pero su peso no es tan
apabullante como podríamos pensar a
simple vista por ejemplo la armada china
es la más grande y poderosa de la región
pero apenas representa en torno al 30
por ciento del tonelaje naval de la zona
es decir que hay competencia queridos
amigos amigas en esta ocasión no vamos a
hablar de los primeros espadas de países
como japón corea del sur australia
taiwán o la propia china no en este
vídeo queremos centrarnos en dos nuevas
potencias militares emergentes de asia
pacifico dos países aún pueden estar muy
lejos de la primera división pero cuya
situación en unos pocos años podría
cambiar radicalmente pero cuáles son
estos países qué influencia pueden
llegar a tener serán acaso los
contrapesos que determinen el futuro
equilibrio de poder entre china y
occidente pues bien vamos a ello
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
fijaos un momento en este mapa
lo que veis es el mar de la china
meridional con las principales
reclamaciones territoriales de los
países que lo bañan como podéis ver es
todo un enorme rompecabezas la disputa
de estas aguas es tan loca que hasta
cuatro países llegan a reclamar al mismo
tiempo exactamente el mismo trozo del
pastel y el problema es que china cada
vez parece menos dispuesta a lidiar con
todo este embrollo al fin y al cabo si
es el país más grande y más fuerte de la
zona porque no imponen su voluntad
porque no hacerse con todo el territorio
que considera suyo y con el control de
todos los recursos naturales que pueden
albergar estas aguas pues sabéis que eso
es exactamente lo que parece pensar xi
jinping y precisamente por eso el
gobierno chino está elevando cada vez
más el tono y sus exigencias sobre estas
reclamaciones territoriales claro que
sus vecinos no se están quedando de
brazos cruzados y se han dicho a sí
mismos cuidado
la república popular china quiere llevar
la voz cantante el problema es que sus
vecinos no están dispuestos a tragar con
su criterio porque una cosa es que china
sea el país más fuerte y otra que se
convierta en una potencia hegemónica así
que si entre el 2003 y el 2018 china
incrementó su presupuesto militar un 600
21% vietnam lo hizo un seiscientos
ochenta y siete por ciento y otros
países como indonesia o tailandia que lo
incrementaron en un 255 por ciento y un
264 respectivamente ahora quieren pisar
aún más el acelerador
digamos que en la escalada militar china
cada vez más países de la zona han
llegado a una conclusión si no nos
preparamos podemos acabar fatal
[Aplausos]
una idea que ahora la invasión rusa de
ucrania ha demostrado que no es una
exageración ni un temor infundado
china ha militarizado completamente tres
islas en el mar de la china meridional
almirante estadounidense y vietnam
fortalece su ejército para enfrentar a
china eeuu refuerza los vínculos
militares en el sudeste asiático para
contrarrestar a china os imagináis que
por ejemplo vietnam la nueva estrella
emergente estaba incrementando su
presupuesto militar incluso más rápido
que la propia china verdad que todo esto
merece un vídeo de visual político pues
atentos
un momento porque tengo una noticia que
daros seguramente la mayoría ya estáis
al tanto pero por si acaso quiero
contaros que la familia de visual
política ha crecido hemos lanzado visual
económica un nuevo canal centrado en una
de nuestras grandes pasiones la economía
un canal de amigos donde indagaremos en
las claves que están detrás de los
principales movimientos económicos del
mundo por ejemplo en el primer vídeo
cuyo enlace os dejo por aquí abajo en la
descripción podréis descubrir la
propuesta que hizo george soros para
transformar europa la emisión de deuda
perpetua de verdad no os lo perdáis
porque estoy seguro de que os encantará
por cierto un millón de gracias a los
más de 35 mil amigos que os suscribiste
incluso antes de lanzar el primer vídeo
eso sí que es confianza muchas
muchísimas gracias dicho esto
continuemos
la historia que no se repetirá
vietnam sabe como nadie lo que supone
enfrentarse a una potencia extranjera
durante todo el siglo 20 se enfrentó con
francia eeuu que os voy a contar y
también con la propia china así que si
algo tienen claro los vietnamitas es que
tienen que estar preparados ante
cualquier eventualidad
[Música]
vietnam y incluyó el refuerzo militar
como uno de los ejes fundamentales de su
famosa política de puesta en marcha en
1986 para reformar su sistema económico
y adoptar paulatinamente un capitalismo
de estado similar al chino incluyó entre
los objetivos la reforma militar porque
hasta ese momento sus fuerzas armadas
eran más parecidas a una serie de grupos
militares fragmentados mal equipados y
mal entrenados con poca correlación
entre sí sin embargo la caída de la
unión soviética supuso un importante
freno para este cambio vietnam era un
país muy pobre y al colapso soviético no
hizo sino empeorar las cosas así que la
modernización militar tuvo que esperar
sin embargo con la llegada del nuevo
siglo y su apertura al mundo la economía
vietnamita empezó a experimentar una
enorme revolución hasta el punto de
convertirse en una de las economías de
mayor crecimiento de todo el mundo lo
que hizo que ya en 2006 el décimo
congreso nacional del partido comunista
de este país se fijara el objetivo de
convertirse en toda una potencia naval
tanto a nivel económico como militar
[Música]
vietnam ha comenzado a equiparse con
armamento relativamente moderno
principalmente de rusia aunque entre sus
inventarios encontramos también fragatas
anti submarinos de corea del sur
helicópteros franceses o drones
israelíes y también y cada vez más
equipos estadounidenses porque a pesar
de su historia las relaciones entre
estados unidos y vietnam se han ido
estrechando en los últimos años
si vietnam es mucho más pobre christina
y su presupuesto militar aún es una
fracción del que tiene su vecino del
norte pero si algo ha demostrado ucrania
es que no hace falta ser el más fuerte
si se tienen ciertas capacidades y sobre
todo se consiguen buenos amigos japón y
vietnam firman un acuerdo de
transferencias de defensa en medio de la
preocupación por china
la vicepresidenta estadounidense kamala
harris realiza una visita histórica a
vietnam todos lo sabemos la guerra de
vietnam ya demostró la trampa que puede
representar este país para una potencia
extranjera así que la estrategia de
hanoi pasa precisamente por incrementar
todo lo posible el coste que para china
tendría intentar hacerse con los islotes
vitaminas en el mar de la china
meridional esto explica por ejemplo
hacer de la flota submarina que
actualmente cuenta con seis unidades en
servicio uno de los elementos
estratégicos de su defensa y es lo que
explica también que haya dedicado muchos
recursos a reforzar las defensas de las
islas que controlan el mar de la china
meridional con lanzacohetes y sistemas
de ataque con alcance suficiente como
para atacar islotes controlados por los
chinos y neutralizar así sus aeródromos
y sistemas de radar
y es que no se trata sólo de una
cuestión política o territorial sino
también y quizás sobre todo económica
vietnam está experimentando un enorme
despegue económico y cada vez son más
las empresas que lo ven como una posible
alternativa china o al menos como una
forma de reducir su exposición al
gigante asiático así que nos resulta
extraño encontrarnos con noticias como
estas samsung invierte 920 millones de
dólares en la expansión de una fábrica
en vietnam el proveedor de apple foxconn
construirá una fábrica en vietnam de 270
millones de dólares en plenas tensiones
eeuu chinas
lg display aumenta su inversión en una
fábrica de vietnam en 1400 millones de
dólares el grupo luego anunciar planes
para construir una fábrica en vietnam
para apoyar el crecimiento a largo plazo
precisamente por este motivo controlar y
garantizar la seguridad y la integridad
de las aguas por las que vietnam exporta
todos esos bienes puede resultar clave
para seguir atrayendo inversión
extranjera directa pero amigos amigas
vietnam no es ni mucho menos el único
país que está comenzando a moverse
[Música]
armas sus mantequillas
a ver si hay un país en el sudeste
asiático que aspira a convertirse en un
actor relevante en la región y si no es
otro que indonesia los dos motivos los
dos mismos que ya hemos visto en el caso
de vietnam básicamente la amenaza de
china y la necesidad de garantizar el
control de las aguas por las que
transitarán sus crecientes exportaciones
al resto del mundo el caso es que en
yakarta parecen haberse cansado de las
constantes incursiones militares chinas
en sus aguas lo que explica que hayan
querido dar un golpe en la mesa al menos
un golpe mediático el derroche aéreo y
naval de indonesia de 125 mil millones
de dólares puede significar 50 buques de
guerra en el mar en los próximos dos
años en medio de las incursiones de
china en la zona económica exclusiva de
indonesia el ministro de defensa bravo
subianto está buscando una gran
inversión en equipo militar a ver la
noticia tiene truco porque lo que se
plantea básicamente es una cifra de
inversión a largo plazo pero este tipo
de anuncios son una forma de decir que
estamos aquí y durante los próximos años
nos vamos a tomar mucho más en serio la
cuestión militar de lo que lo hemos
hecho hasta ahora y es que lo cierto es
que la cuestión militar como ocurre en
la mayoría de los países de la zona ha
sido históricamente algo secundario y de
hecho hardware militar de indonesia no
solo es viejo muy viejo sino que además
buena parte de él se encuentra en un
estado calamitoso
por ejemplo en julio de 2020 se les
hundió un buque de desembarco de los
años 70 comprado alemania del este en
2021 perdieron un submarino de 40 años
en unas prácticas de torpedos resultando
en la muerte de 53 marineros y luego los
accidentes con aviones de entrenamiento
y ataque ligero están a la orden del día
pero ahora la idea es que todo esto
cambie entre los materiales que podrían
llegar en los próximos años encontramos
equipos como el rav el francés nuevas
versiones del f-15 norteamericano o el
nuevo caza surcoreano acá efe 21 en cuyo
programa de desarrollo por cierto
participa la propia indonesia pero sobre
todo la estrategia militar de este país
tiene como prioridad desarrollar lo que
se conoce como una armada de aguas
verdes un término que se refiere a las
fuerzas navales especializadas en la
defensa costera lo que por un lado le
permitiría controlar el territorio
nacional no olvidemos que hablamos de un
país que tiene más de 17 mil islas y por
otro dificultaría cualquier ambición que
china pudiera tener sobre ellas la idea
es un poco la que hemos visto en ucrania
puede ser sí mucho muchísimo más fuerte
pero atrévete a meterte en un avispero
como éste
es lo que se conoce como disuasión
psicológica operativa una estrategia que
pasa por crear una defensa marítima que
haga que cualquier incursión enemiga
tenga un coste lo suficientemente
elevado como para que el posible enemigo
descarte por completo sus planes que la
relación coste-beneficio no les haga
cuenta
pero para entender mejor qué está detrás
de este objetivo podemos echar un
vistazo por ejemplo a las islas nature a
272 islas bajo soberanía indonesia que
sin embargo están dentro de la línea de
los 9 puntos que reclama china unas
islas que además vienen con regalos se
estima amigos que en su subsuelo hay más
de 5 millones de metros cúbicos de gas
lo que podría convertirlas en uno de los
mayores yacimientos de todo el mundo e
insisto son reclamadas como propias por
china seguro que ahora entendéis mejor
el empeño indonesio por desarrollar
rápidamente esa armada de aguas verdes
de esta forma la idea es equipar su
fuerza naval con doscientos setenta y
cuatro barcos diez escuadrones de
combate aéreo y doce nuevos submarinos
diesel entre otro equipamiento indonesia
busca triplicar la flota de submarinos
tras incursiones chinas claro que
también hay un problema muchos expertos
apuntan a que los misiles guiados de
precisión chinos junto a otros avances
tecnológicos como pueden ser los propios
drones le permitirían a pekín a atacar y
limpiar la zona antes siquiera de
penetrar en la zona económica exclusiva
de indonesia es lo que se conoce como
guerra desde casa
sea como sea amigos el caso es que
vietnam e indonesia son dos ejemplos de
economías emergentes que ahora están
empezando a tomarse en serio esta
cuestión y ojo porque entre los dos
países en poco tiempo sumarán más de 400
millones de habitantes y un creciente
desarrollo económico es decir que no
hablamos precisamente de un potencial
pequeño ahora bien fijaos un momento en
este otro mapa
recordáis lo que decíamos antes del
tonelaje de las fuerzas navales de la
región china se está convirtiendo en una
superpotencia pero es una potencia
rodeada que difícilmente podrá lograr la
hegemonía fijaos insisto en el mapa
fijaos en corea del sur-japón en
filipinas en taiwán en vietnam e
indonesia juntos vendrían a formar una
especie de barrera de seguridad capaz de
limitar mucho las ambiciones de china y
que obligaría en este país a prestar
atención a demasiados frentes distintos
por eso la mejora de las capacidades de
vietnam indonesia y también filipinas
puede resultar geopolíticamente tan
importante sobre todo cuando estos
países están estrechando lazos con eeuu
corea del sur o japón según los casos
amigos el partido no está ni mucho menos
cerrado la guerra de ucrania ha
expoliado el deseo de todos estos países
de mejorar sus capacidades para evitar
convertirse en una futura ucrania tiene
sentido no os parece pero llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti cuáles crees que
serán las futuras potencias militares
del mundo hasta dónde llegará el poder
de china logrará convertirse en una
potencia hegemónica en asia-pacífico
hasta donde llegará a esta carrera
militar déjanos tus impresiones por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y por cierto no
te olvides de echarle un vistazo a
visual económica ya nos dirás qué te
parece una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]